ils ont décidé de changer de profession
pour travailler dans le domaine de
l'agriculture ou dans les chantiers
forestiers une reconversion
professionnelle pour florian ancien
ingénieur qui a décidé de faire la
formation maraîchage je pense que c'est
une filière d'avenir pour tout ce qui
touche aux enjeux aux enjeux du xxième
siècle tout ce qui touche à
l'environnement à l'agriculture pour
essayer de trouver des solutions à
l'avenir pour une agriculture pérenne
pour cette formation il faut pratiquer
pour apprendre dans la serre de
production morgan formatrice en
maraîchage apprend à rempoter du persil
à anna et florian dans cette serre on à
la serre de production donc du coup on
va produire tous les végétaux on vient
quatre heures en tp donc du coup ils ont
des choses à faire que je leur donne le
matin à faire et ensuite tout simplement
il éxécuté il me demande lorsqu'ils ne
comprennent pas dont les 21 et art du
centre horticole
on trouve aussi la filière bois après
plusieurs blessures causées par son
ancienne profession d'orient en scindant
soir professionnel a décidé de se
reconvertir
je suis venu en formation ici en fait
parce que de base je cherchais à devenir
élagueurs et il faut maintenant un
diplôme de niveau iv délivré par le
ministère de l'agriculture
donc la formation permettait d'avoir une
équivalence et c'était en rapport avec
avec avec le métier d'élagueur donc je
commençais à prendre l'apprentissage
abus
à la tronçonneuse
aux métiers du bois en général une
formation qui dure neuf mois avec des
stages à effectuer pour posséder toutes
les connaissances et les appliquer sur
le terrain sont en danger
ça va commencer en début de formation
par des petites interventions plutôt de
l'observation et puis petit à petit vont
prendre la main donc ils vont porter la
machine comme machine on va avoir de la
tronçonneuse pour tout ce qui est en
entretien des arbres abattage soin des
arbres un apprentissage rapide et une
prise en charge par la région pour
décrocher le diplôme et pouvoir se
reconvertir